the day Sony Pictures Disney and Marvel
Studios spider-man deal came to an end
is one that will live on in infamy the
news was and remains a huge deal since
Sony and Disney the parent company of
Marvel Studios were unable to
renegotiate the terms of their original
2015 deal that saw Marvel producing
spider-man movies with Sony retaining
ownership Tom Hollands spider-man is out
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
potentially for good fans the world over
were shocked upon hearing the news and
it's no exaggeration to say that the
response to spider-man leaving the MCU
has been emotional pop culture junkie
comic book enthusiast and filmmaker
Kevin Smith took to Twitter to bank Sony
to agree to Disney's terms and keep
spider-man in the MCU No just stop it
please
Sony Pictures give Disney what they want
and many millions of us will keep giving
you our money
Smith's tweet was in reference to the
reports that Disney requested a 50%
co-financing share in the spider-man
film franchise and asked to retain
producing status on future films
credited to Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige Sony is said to have
flat-out refused the proposition as
there was evidently no way the studio
would be comfortable with increasing
Marvel's current 5 percent cuts of the
franchise's first day profits to a 50
percent stake on that note Uproxx senior
entertainment writer Mike Ryan argued
that Sony is in the right for walking
away as it would be unreasonable to
expect the studio to bump up Disney's
share from 5 percent to 50 percent
Ryan posted on Twitter people seem to be
mad at Sony for spider-man in the MCU
separating if you read the deadline
piece it sounds like Disney raised its
price from 5 percent to 50 percent which
is a lot it's not insane Sony didn't
agree to that I'll pay the usual rate
Ryan wasn't the only one who felt this
way Marvel fan Ahmad Mansoor tweeted
that Sony was smart not to bend to
Disney's whims given that the studio
Spidey franchise has been flourishing as
of late spider-man far from home
recently became Sony's highest earning
film of all time
it's 2018 animated flick spider-man into
the spider versus an Academy Award
winner and its venom franchise kicked
off with an impressive 856 million
dollar worldwide poll which recently
motivated Sony to green-light a sequel
with director Andy Serkis
the user wrote it all sums up to money
and greed I mean did Disney really think
that Sony would let them share 5050 in
revenue 1090 max maybe it just became
their highest-grossing movie of all time
with venom and into the spider-verse
proceeds it's their goldmine now the
Twitter account for fandom dot-com joke
that VG must have had the same
conversation with Disney CEO Bob Iger
that Tony Stark had with Steve Rogers at
the start of Avengers endgame in the
film Tony told Steve that he lost the
KITT referring to the fact that Peter
Parker got dusted in Thanos his Avengers
infinity war snap and there was nothing
Tony could do to save him though Disney
apparently did try to keep Holland
spider-man in the MCU Sony pulled him
into its web in the end
on the subject of comparing Sony to
Thanos many filled the studio has a lot
in common with the intergalactic tyrant
for not continuing to negotiate with
Disney and Marvel countless others are
concerned that spider-man's exit from
the MCU means that the euros
relationship with Tony Stark not to
mention the ending of far from home
won't be followed up on one user wrote
on Twitter how to Sony not understand
that they just can't erase everything
that has happened in endgame what do
they think they're famous now snap and
you can just erase Spidey from existence
and everything he's been through with
Tony nope
saves spider-man another added so Sony
has replaced Stannis as the primary
villain of the MCU many other fans like
Twitter user bas hi Joe all but shouted
their outrage as that user put it Tony
Stark didn't die to say Peter Parker for
Sony to take him out of the MCU
save spider-man things went from bad to
worse when Sony issued its response to
the deals apparent collapse a company
spokesperson stated we are disappointed
but respect Disney's decision not to
have Kevin Feige continued as a lead
producer of our next live-action
spider-man film we hope this might
change in the future but understand that
the many new responsibilities that
Disney has given him including all their
newly added Marvel properties do not
allow time for him to work on IP they do
not own one fan expressed hope for some
kind of agreement to be reached in the
future directly addressing Sony on
Twitter with a post that reads I
respectfully request that you return to
the negotiating table and make a deal
that will please us the fans for our
parts the only hope we have for Sony's
two forthcoming spider-man movies is
that whatever they do they just don't
make us watch Uncle Ben die again check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]